no I have not been a member before
from another political party
eh no this is my first time
so it's a deep dive
say goodbye to the vvd
because there were more and more points of view
and what I did not agree with the VVD
from a national local party
I have never been a member
that wouldn't suit me either
then I would feel that I am too much in a box
should sit
why now
because this is a club that leaves a lot of space
mister quack former member of the cda
why now GDP
caroline is doing fine in the second room
she can speak an understood number
a clear language
she doesn't spin around the pot
she missed a reach with the cda
that was at the vvd
that was also a bit away from home
and why leave that party
well I actually had little confidence
in policy at the beginning of this century
I was right about that afterwards
emptying other parties is not the intention
because that's really up to the people themselves
if they feel at home with the bbb
yes look
as people
is that the enthusiasm maybe at the beginning
yes of course
you say something sometimes
let's think
I might have had better
have to articulate something else
well this is one of them